bro I put some lotion on me don't put
some lotion on my can write down I mean
I got some pretty colors in here they
waited you can't even tell what up what
up - chimes on with the TR you crew TR
you as the acronym that means the real
you the real University it's about
celebrate your individualism over here
and being comfortable in your own skin
hot sleeper oh well I'm schooling ain't
been getting on tattoos lately but I got
a lot of them
my first tattoo on my face I started
going crazy on the arms and the body
right here too long the temple it hurt
but you realize I don't need to play my
body period just hurts so I stopped
getting excellent all my tattoos me
something everyone on to w's while the
word that's my name the horseshoe is
placed in four seasons like where we
hang it and I was in our shoots off my
phone slept on my face I got my face up
like 16 17
[Music]
feel my legs go first out of hand for my
dad my mom she cared but she didn't like
care you know I got her man first you
know hurt my sister name and dog ticks
first and then I just went crazy on the
list I had to give a name
first though so they one say nothing and
my dad he knew I know nobody told on me
they probably did but he knew he just
walked in the house one day and just
pull my pants up so after he knew and he
wasn't tripping
I went body home hold up side of my
brother no done except my plead the
fifth and I don't know nobody named no
artist name would be the tattoos and
nothing home you know I had but I got
I'm kind of being on the picture thing
just a visual of something other than
just words I have like hands-on science
hot times just think of miracle it's
much my grandmother my paint as Lee K
Smith well she died at 3 o'clock and I
put 3 o'clock with her lifeline and food
see how they hear my guitar
you better leave that boy alone he do
that he won't goddamn do then my my
partner smokey got killed off of some
Twitter book I play them on the side and
blue chucks with the brick wall they
make me want to go in my face a lot
every day I see him both my brothers
you wanna I'll tell my brother my found
sure I'd be wanna everyone just go crazy
[Music]
you know I'm on this run
I got my own dad in jail I got a peat
pot with Stefan he's in the room to put
it eight different times so it was like
different times while I was in there you
feel then I gotta burn it and I'm ill
the rich on my neck - my man she passed
away I got my face hit I had to roll
some other assistance she passed
Yeah right you know that triple cross
right there
super car came in a lot if you know you
know or her beverage have the real right
hitting on the real that guy's honesty
uh-huh car agency 813 I'm gonna get a
writer
I like 15 only that little Jake owes her
Delphi took in my life the outfit team
up on got hit with a stick sanitizing
trick I would put sound bullets on that
what it
I started here now face up and we got a
long little minnow there's another one
right there I got a long reach inside
the roll 19:42 another dip on it I want
to put a lot beer right here down yeah
and I break up we got now put the Block
on a lap with the bird so I gotta eat
iPhone even know I could even fly blow
everything I ain't nothing in the animal
kingdom that flat you stop it you an
eagle fly boy every time I'm telling you
about there if there's a grit in it I
was high Frontex world
I regret that touch me I wish I would've
never gotten so big baby wishes so
excited to take me holds all my good
stuff like my favorite touch around you
say everything I need little love is my
pleasure one it was around the time
where bugs again like sleeves I said I
was gonna sock so I got a tattoo so it
got like a little genie thing the genie
came out hill I was standing the
apartments with AC hanging out the one
and somebody came and grinding in my
weed
I actually had a bad experience with one
of my G's on my leg I went in a shark I
was getting a touch of like eight hours
straight and I started getting the
cheers and their time threw up and
everything I think he was just in the
same spot for too long or something but
it was one of them tattoos I supposed to
get in a couple of days a couple of
sessions and I told him I
because position I was ready to do it
and I think just getting poked on for
seven eight hours straight she's
probably freaked my body out of the Sun
the common denominator of all of us is
that we all got them young who didn't
need any type of a permission to get
them we just kind of got him but they
all have some kind of meaning associated
to you that's just like a thing and then
they sound like we all got our mom to to
try to take the heat off that's kind of
like the thing you do first is get your
mom so she can't get mad she might try
to get mad once you see her nice you got
my baby love I'm a my mom playing space
and I was in the back of one party used
to put me in the back room kitties to be
doing a bunch of stuff Danny wanted me
to see I heard her telling folks my baby
got my name on him and I often run up a
little bit GQ tattoo we are the TR you
crew we all got some pain written on us
eat dust
we all got scars that we covered up with
tattoos
no I'm saying and I'm no face no cases
the name of our compilation dropped in
February 7 where you will be able to
hear some of that pain you know I'm
saying over some heart SB